في المعركه تاتيك الضربه من كل مكان لا
تدري اين مكمان الخطر
والخطر قد يكون من الهواتف الجوال
تصدر الهواتف الجوال اشارات عند استخدامها
من قبل الجنود
تتصل تلك الاشارات بشبكه الخلويه للجهه
المقابله ما يسمح عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
بتحديد مكان وموقع الجنود
تلقائيا يتم حفظ معلومات رقم معرفه الجهاز
ورقم التجوال وبالطبع تحركات الجنود
استقبال تلك المعلومات يتم عبر اجهزه
الاستخبارات الغربيه تتوفر لها قدرات
هائله للرصد والمتابعه يتم ارسال
الاحداثيات التي تم التوصل اليها للقوات
الاوكرانيه
لتستفيد من تلك المعلومات في ضرب مواقع
الجنود بالصواريخ او المسيارات
طريقه اخرى باستخدام منظومه لير 3 المكونه
من طائرتين مسيرتين ومركز قياده في شاحنه
عسكريه لتتبع مواقع الهاتف ويمكن لهذه
المنظومه رصد اكثر من الفيهاتف محمول في
مدن يصل الى خمسه كيلومترات و 400 متر مما
يتيح امكانيه العثور على مجموعه كامله من
القوات الروسيه كاشف مواقع القوات
المنافسه يتم ايضا من خلال استخدام اجهزه
راديو وواي فاي وبلوتوث وعدم تشفير
الملفات الحساسه وتنزيل التطبيقات غير
الموثقه
خطا يقع فيه الكثير من الجنود والنتيجه
فقدان ارواحهم بيدي هواتفهم المحموله التي
تطلق عليهم طلقه مميته